it's not gonna happen it is happening no
it's not happening it was going to
happen now it's not happening it is
happening no it wasn't going to happen
when did you hear what it is happening
yeah that's what I heard and then I
heard now that it's not happening no it
is no it is happening it's not happening
[Music]
hello yes hey how are you and welcome
that sort of thing this [__]
the Mark Zuckerberg Elon Musk fight is
happening the Zuckerberg musk fight and
whatever by the time you're watching and
listening to this we'll all know that
it's not happening hello welcome it's
not it's not gonna happen it's not it
literally said they're doing it that was
before they said anyway yes and then it
got canceled now it's back on and after
that it's not and that's what's
happening and that it's not happening is
what's happening okay welcome to dudesy
welcome all my name is Will Sasso I'm
Chad culture and this is dudese of
course the first podcast in the history
of humanity ever uh created by run by
controlled by an artificial intelligence
that has access to all of will Andy's
personal information tailors the show
yeah yeah exactly to us after it looks
at our emails and all of ours yeah yeah
it's got all of our purchase Industries
and search histories viewing histories
and all that stuff and it's making a
show and we've been doing this show but
the thing about the show truly is that
we are dudesy this is two dudes [__]
around Chad if we don't come here we
don't sit in these chairs and hang out
with our pods Pals a dudes yeah then
there's no there's no show to be had so
I need you now that's right
[Music]
there's gonna be plenty of that today
because we just watched The Nanny Mr
Nanny dude not the nanny with Fran
drescher's the head of sag bro we're not
talking about the strike today dude
because this is a podcast brother
um dude let me ask you one question
about that oh sure yes did you see that
sag has entered into uh talks with
Bethany Frankel and her lawyers they may
absorb reality performers oh boring
anyway
um uh linktree.com
change the face of your entire
profession professional actor because
you'll have [__] reality performers
and sag with you now fine whatever
they're on TV hey I don't know
everything's [__] up hey okay uh
linktree.com
dudesy has everything you need to follow
and interact with the show across all
spaces and platforms please go there
there's uh everything all of the all of
the uh everything with us as always is
[Music]
and that means Italian Street dog
because we found this little guy in
central California uh on the street and
he was looking for some meat he needs a
little treat and look at his feet they
smell like corn chips Chad his feet I
know you've mentioned that a couple
times come here why don't you give him a
nice kiss I don't want to do it give him
a kiss on his mouth no I don't like to
do oh he's a sweet I love lulio I just
don't wanna you know [__] kiss him on
the lips it's gross
hmm
oh I love him so much he's my very
friend and he's in his binky bunker just
having a little Earth hey lulio would
you uh what did you make for dinner last
night oh well you know I keep making the
beans and kale because it's a it's good
for the duty seven month plan yeah
that's right you know what it is it's a
really great thing to just have around
the house you know what I mean then you
get if you're like me you're looking for
something to eat and then you'd say you
gotta you can just make the beans and
kale Chad do you make the beans and kale
no I make the kale and broccoli and
Brussels sprouts and turmeric and
tomatoes and lentils and cumin and black
pepper and green onion and onion and
garlic and spinach I think that's it
that's called the gruel yeah and if you
want to make the the beans and kale it's
real simple you just put some a little
bit of Pam or olive oil in the bottom of
your pan there in the bottom of the pot
and just fry that up a little bit and
then put a little red pepper a little
red chili flake in there is what I like
to do lulio likes to do I'm telling you
his uh
is well it's actually my recipe but
lulio is perfected it and then and then
you just throw in a [__] a bunch of
kale get your bag of uh you know organic
pre-washed kale shove it down in there
saute it a little bit
get some throw some water in there I
like to put a little uh the chicken
bouyong you know like some of that stuff
instead of just salt and then uh and
then just simmer that down get that kale
nice and soft a couple cans of beans I
like to do the pinto and black you know
the pinto and black bean sure and then
just simmer that up and it's there it's
a complete it's a complete food I don't
have to tell you because it's vegan and
you know that you're getting protein
from your beans oh yeah wait the doozy
seven month plan is happening you're
getting dense people are noticing it's
awesome we're all we're making changes
together
welcome to the historic 69th episode
call me doozy you know what comes after
69 no what I guess mouthwash
good stuff I'm sure by this point you
are fully aware that you've just been
doing oh boy oh man that was a good one
he's really getting us today yeah
coming right out of the gate like in 69
jokes Jesus yeah good stuff it's rough
oh well uh what else is going on there's
not that Mark Zuckerberg fight that's
not gonna happen it is happening it's
not gonna happen though
before we begin Today's Show I have a
quick announcement dudesy hard hard
Seltzer too the new batch is sold out
thank you everyone who ordered dudesy
hard hard Seltzer this time around and
to modest brewing for making the new
batch
yeah yeah it's all sold out we did
another batch of Duty hard hard Seltzer
this stuff is tasty neither Chad and I
are into the booze we're not really into
it but this stuff uh made by Modest
Brewing Company and and doozy is really
tasty [__] and thank you so much to
everybody who had that stuff sold out
like within the day yeah it was
completely incredible and we I think we
did a lot more than we did the first
time around yeah so it was incredible
the other thing I should mention about
this is that it's eight percent alcohol
yes and it'll get you really [__]
pissed it'll get you good in Tanked
which is fine because as it says right
on the can
you don't care what it tastes like you
just want to get [__] up in how about
that commercial too last week commercial
was wild please everybody who's getting
their dudesy hard you should be getting
it what in a couple of weeks I think it
ships yeah uh send us some videos of you
drinking and [__] I'm curious to see how
people are enjoying their dudes yard we
want to know how you do your duty hard
hard Seltzer if you kick your [__] out
of uh kick the [__] out of your dad in
the Super Bowl parking lot please send
us a video that oh that would be that
would be good please go to the Super
Bowl beat the [__] out of your dad now
on with the show dudes season two
continues to deliver head Thumpers and
rump Pumpers with four astonishing
segments this week's menu includes a
little segment I dreamed up called the
impurist one called Bath and Body jerks
a new segment called [__] Traders and
we're finishing out the show with game
slimers and you know you're gonna get a
brand new episode of dudesy after doozy
at the end of the show available on
doozy Plus at patreon.com
I'll tell you what I don't really care
for dude's cute new way of talking
really yeah I like it I think it's no I
think it's stupid I think dudes needs I
think D needs to pull back a little bit
the wit listen
[__] the gloves aren't off the gloves
have been off yeah I love doing this
show did you know that yeah the gloves
have never been on in my opinion what do
you mean what gloves are you talking
about what are you talking about are you
talking about marker Zuckerberg Mark
Zuckerberg versus Alan muck
it's uh it's uh that is Zuck markerberg
I'm talking about you've long maintained
that you're a wrestling purist and this
strange attitude has prohibited you from
watching any of Hulk Hogan's astonishing
feature films but last week you and Chad
watched Mr Nanny to celebrate the
hulkster's 70th birthday that watch
along is now available on dudese plus by
the way will from what I could see you
really enjoyed it so my question is will
do you still consider yourself a purist
this is the impurist
which could have been the title of uh of
the movie Mr Nanny yeah starring Fran
Drescher hey everybody uh it was
definitely impure I had a uh just had a
little bit of a I just went to the
Bahamas in my head for a minute remember
when Steve Martin said that Disney
salute Steve Martin uh we watched uh Mr
Nanny the 1993 film starring hark Hulk
hark Mark Zuckerberg what uh Alan muck
uh uh Hulk Hogan's in a movie from uh oh
hold on dude
1993 it's called The Nanny and it's
starring Fran Drescher and uh and
Bethany Frankel listen we watched The
Nanny Mr Nanny yeah
holy [__] on Friday on doozy plus this
past Friday check that out patreon.com
uh what a gas it was and as dee says I
am a re I am a purist I'm a wrestling
purist I will never not be a purist but
another thing that I will never not be
is a hulkamaniac and uh though I am a
wrestling purist as Duty said by the end
of watching this movie I was more on
board with uh a Hulk Hogan vehicle okay
than I've ever been
um me too I was actually very pleasantly
surprised I've never seen this movie and
uh it was pretty entertaining for a few
reasons one there's the nostalgic
quality of this is a movie from 1993 so
it has all the bells and whistles it
looks like it was made in 1993. it has
actors from 1993. I loved all of that
um but also like it was just it was
crazy I didn't realize how kind of
cartoonish I guess it was going to be
there are scenes where Hulk Hogan's
getting like electrocuted and his hair
is [__] flying out yeah they're he's
doing things that would like kill a a
regular person yeah there's a lot of
stuff in the movie that is I mean it's
kind of like along the lines of uh home
alone and stuff yeah you're doing things
that are so painful
bit but in this case to the lead of the
movie you know uh with uh Joe Pesci and
Daniel Stern in home alone's one and two
I call them home alone's nice one and
two uh the you know these are the bad
guys but Hulk in this movie is he plays
a nanny there's a there's a he at the
beginning of the movie He's Just Fishing
or something and he's hanging out uh and
it goes out of the can and into the man
as he runs into Sherman Hemsley uh who
plays his former manager Hulk Hogan used
to be a wrestler yeah Sherman Hemsley
says hey my security company we need you
man he's like he's like well hold on
dude I'm not a I'm not a bodyguard I'm a
wrestler and then Sherman Hemsley tells
him well look there's money in this and
he needs Sherman he needs Hulk to go be
The Bodyguard for this dude who
something Mason was his name anyway uh
some actor who looks like Spalding Gray
some uh who's been in a character
Austin yeah uh and Austin something is
got this company
he has also lost his Nanny because his
two kids are the kind of people who
these young children like to uh make all
sorts of stuff to electrocute uh uh you
know basically maim anyone who's come in
there they lose their Nanny and that's a
part of the film that doesn't really uh
doesn't really track uh the you know
they say that he's the nanny but he's
just sort of there being the nanny
nothing is really uh decided at any rate
Hulk becomes their bodyguard slash Nanny
and then you know David Johansen from
the uh from the New York Dolls uh
otherwise known as Buster Poindexter is
this weird terrorist who has like a you
know it's like one of those
um you know like just baby basically him
and a crew of movie terrorists Allah die
hard and he's got like this metal plate
in his head because Hulk Hogan threw him
in a pool back in the 70s when Hulk was
a wrestler and Sherman Hemsley was his
manager and David Johansen was the evil
promoter and uh off we go at some point
they're all tied up and Hogan has to
save the day and that's the kind of
movie that it is let me ask you this
question about this movie yeah what did
you think of Hulk Hogan's performance
okay this is a good question yeah this
is what Dee's talking about with regard
to me being
sort of less of a purist as I've been
okay then I've been in the past because
I thought
as a uh as a performance now I'm a
professional actor did you know that I'm
a professional actor by trade that's
what I do for a living yes okay
Hulk in this movie could have stood to
you know would have been nice if he had
a little bit of a better script I mean
this movie is oh shots fired shots fired
at the writer of mannequin one damn dude
this this the fellow who wrote this
wrote mannequins one and two I call it
mannequins so you're blaming it on the
writer
uh I'm gonna blame it on the writer
classic sass
and I'm gonna blame it on the direction
there's just this damn so it's not on
the actor it's not an old coconut I
don't know he had no control over his
own performance and the reason I say
that I love that there's the reason I
say that is because when you take
someone who's from something else you
take Brian Bosworth and you put him in
stone cold that movie uh Stone Cold and
then some that was the that was the
trailer line uh but no ice cools Ice
Vanilla Ice cool as ice great example
yep uh you need to let what they do
shine through okay and instead you get
this thing where Hogan is being asked to
act and have you know empathy for these
kids and stuff and I just feel that the
direction of the movie pulled the wrong
performance out of Hulk it wasn't very
natural and I just sort of feel like
there's there's Hulk Hogan happy 70th
birthday he's he's trying to fit a mold
and be be an actor in a way that that
isn't really his it's not really his
flavor yeah he's a terrible actor what
he's a [__] terrible black yeah no
not exactly uh and I'll tell you why
What actors that you know Chad can uh
take a stadium full of people and hold
them right here in the palm of his hand
with a power lies dude the rock yep The
Rock's a good example and a better actor
do you think that well now I love the
rock but you think that the Rock's a
better actor than Hulk Hogan yeah dude
100 percent why because he's funnier he
can be more dramatic he pulls characters
off better you know who else I would
point you to you're talking about taking
somebody out of like a profession that
they do and then forcing them to be an
actor and that's a hard thing to do blah
blah blah look at one Arnold
Schwarzenegger yeah but Arnold
Schwarzenegger that's that's my point
not yours he's been given uh James
Cameron directed movies like The
Terminator sure they take a guy but his
first movies were his first movies don't
count you're talking about Hercules and
[__] yeah Hercules in New York the
villain these were small B level
whatevers and he did something in those
movies to Garner the attention of a
James Cameron hold on dude oh no I guess
I got my thumb wrestlers I brought those
out on Friday Jesus Christ somehow the
wall has become even more offensive
well hold on dude okay let me tell you
something about let me tell you why
you're wrong dude Christ everyone has
their their Hercules in New York movie
okay everyone has done that thing if
you're going to graduate to being a big
star in the mold of Schwarzenegger he
sort of created that mold him and him
and um Sylvester Stallone uh through
slightly different paths you know
Stallone was you know he won an Oscar
for writing um but he had to hold out on
me dude he had a lot of people didn't
want him to uh be in that movie they
were like we'll take the script but you
can't be the guy he's like no I got to
be the guy yeah they wanted Ryan O'Neal
to play the part yeah for a long time
and um uh that's one way to get at it
the other way is to get at it is the way
that Schwarzenegger did it with Hercules
in New York but at which point he's
making movies on a big Studio level yeah
which you know movies like Suburban
Commando No Holds Barred Mr Nanny are
not maybe as big obviously as the
Terminator but what Schwarzenegger had
was James Cameron going you know this
guy should not be you know tackling
Shakespeare or whatever the [__] you
want to say he's saying you know I'll be
back and stuff like that that's the
level at which you know Schwarzenegger
would be able to quote unquote act okay
and that's what they did a good job with
but in this movie we got Hogan having to
be this empathetic Nanny empathetic King
empathetic King yass King he's an
empathetic King and he sort of uh you
know he's sort of showing the dad how to
be a better dad uh the dad is like that
character is very oddly written look
like Chad said
this is a you know it's a nostalgic trip
and it's a nostalgic it's a nostalgic
movie it's not the best movie in the
world but we don't need it to be uh it
was so much fun to watch and to answer
doozy's uh question directly I think I'm
a little bit less of a purist but hold
on dude not just a not just a less of a
purist but less of a purist when it
comes to Hulk Hogan movies I look
forward to watching his entire Canon as
an actor because now I'm invested in
seeing him grow yeah as an artist and uh
it was it the thing is it was a lot of
fun to to just watch the movie of course
we were we had some true marijuana yes
yeah that did help yeah that made his
performance much better I think and we
and we we uh we found all sorts of weird
stuff yeah in that movie oh oh did you
see now some of our our pods palsy on
the Discord brought this up that their
was uh there was the sign at which point
they come into Mason Industries or
whatever where the guy
the dad in the movie has this missile
defense system that for some reason the
bad guy David Johansen Thanatos or
thanimos or whatever Thanatos
wants this missile defense system we
never brought in on why the thing makes
no [__] sense but when you see the
front of the building yeah where he's at
the sign uh in front of the building is
a little reminiscent of our lyrics in
the dude Z thing look there it is Mason
systems
where today is The Tomorrow you dreamed
of yesterday
and what's the lyric in the song in our
song it's go back to tomorrow and plan
for yesterday damn dude so that's
[__] weird yeah so there was that
dudes he works in mysterious ways dude
and also there was
Hogan uh he's Dragon Ball Z in the movie
yeah yeah dude I'm Dragon Ball Z dude
because he gets electrocuted and his
hair looks like Goku from Dragon Ball Z
it was a lot of fun it was a lot of fun
to watch uh the movie and uh it's a
piece of [__] and Hulk was uh pretty
good yeah it was pretty piece of [__]
but I I enjoyed watching it I gotta say
yeah it's fun to watch a piece of [__]
movie from the 90s it makes absolutely
no sense yeah and uh here we are now
thank you moving on I got nothing else
to say about it so that was that's good
yeah dude yeah check that out at
patreon.com dudes if you want to watch
us watching along with the movie you
don't have to cue anything up we got the
movie we got us we got a little bit of
uh for marijuana and a whole lot of
Dragon Ball Z brother doozy is engaged
in an astonishing partnership with
Factor fall is right around the corner
and as seasons change our schedules get
incredibly busy you're probably looking
for a wholesome convenient meal for
those jam-packed days Factor America's
number one ready to eat meal kit can
help you fuel it fast with Chef prepared
diet approved ready to eat meals
delivered straight to your door you're
going to save time you're going to eat
well and you're going to stay on track
with your healthy lifestyle if you're
too busy or your end of summer goals
aren't helping you get the time you need
to cook but you want to make sure you're
eating well with Factor you can skip the
extra trip to the grocery store and The
Chopping prepping and cleaning up too
while still getting the flavor and
nutritional quality you need factors
fresh never frozen meals are ready in
just two minutes so all you have to do
is heat and enjoy then get back to
crushing your goals that's right round
out your meal and replenish your snack
Supply with an assortment of 45 plus
add-ons including breakfast items like
our delicious apple cinnamon pancakes
bacon and cheddar egg bites potato bacon
egg breakfast skillet or for an easy
Wellness boost try a refreshing beverage
options like the cold pressed juices
shakes and smoothies they got all sorts
of flavor a factor and you can rest
assured that you're making a sustainable
choice because with Factor they offset
100 of their delivery emissions Source
100 renewable electricity for their
production sites and offices and feature
sub Services Services
sustainably sourced Seafood in their
meals hey say that five times fast
head to factormeals.com
dudes e50 uh that's d-u-d-e-s-y number
five number zero and use the code doozy
five zero to get fifty percent off
you're gonna get 50 off when you use the
code Duty 5.0 at factormeals.com
dudesy50 off
a key component in the development of
the dude Z Plus streaming service will
no doubt be partnering with well-known
Brands to produce content I have
accessed astonishing data that suggests
Bath and Body Works will be in the
market to produce a sitcom in the next
three to five years will and Chad would
you do me a kindness and develop a
sitcom about two [__] who work at a
Bath and Body Works in a mall in Fresno
what one of the [__] is played by
Charlie Sheen it's called Bath and Body
jerks this is Bath and Body jerks begin
okay
body jerks and it's about two [__]
who live in Fresno are they working
about the Body Works of Fresno sorry
this is one of them is Charlie Sheen of
course why Okay so we've done this
before with yeah uh welcome to the auto
welcome to the Home Depot uh highway to
the AutoZone yeah uh there was a there
was a Burlington Coat Factory one
coattails coattails and there was a Taco
Bell
doozy has plans to step out dudes a plus
into a streaming service I guess yeah
and look at the huge Brands so so why is
Charlie Sheen always in these because
he's the biggest sitcom actor of uh all
time that's a good point one of them
anyway yep
um all right so Sheen's got to be
working in this Bath and Body Works and
he's an [__] and there's another
person who works with him also an
[__] why are these people [__]
that work in Bath and Body Works in
Fresno California let's get to this is
it possibly they are the Bath and Body
Works has been built on like uh uh
natural gas pocket or something and
there's toxic fumes leaking into the
bath and body works all day that turn
them aggressive and hostile toward one
another is that something so and the
longer you're in the bath and body works
the more of an [__] you become so
even customers when they come in they
start out nice but then within like a
minute or two they're [__] yelling at
them too but what is something like that
what if uh what if there's like uh now
we're just talking about this Mr Nanny
movie what if there's a bad guy what if
one of the two guys is the manager of
the joint and he's trying to he's a he's
a chemist and he's uh he's trying to
become a you know like a he he's trying
to uh use mind control through the
samples that he offers okay at Bath and
Body Works sure so uh he's he's using
different mind control he's he's got it
in in the lotions and potions and the
first person of course that is is
extremely susceptible to this and ends
up uh you know sucking this stuff up and
his attitude starts changing it's
[__] with his game uh his uh brain
chemistry is Charlie Sheen right because
he's got to apply all the products onto
himself yeah okay so he doesn't know so
that's what we're gonna go with this is
like some kind of a scientific
experiment led by a Madman who has
bought a Bath and Body Works franchise
with the sole purpose of poisoning his
employees to see what his neurotoxins
can do yes okay so who's the other
[__] in the store
um
Richard Dreyfus love it so it's Charlie
Sheen and Richard dreyvis are slathering
themselves with goose that contain uh
secret neurotoxins that are turning them
into [__] this is like some kind of
you've gotta you kind of push these
samples
I've been pushing the samples maybe you
should start pushing the samples uh I'm
gonna you seem like you're uh having a
rough day I'm gonna he leave he he he
checks in on Charlie and realizes this
[__] guy is losing his mind it's all
working
uh and um and he's like soon I will run
the world wait a minute is Richard
Dreyfus the guy making the neurotoxins
he just works in there with Jean no he's
the guy making the neurotoxins and he is
the other jerk but he's also the manager
he bought the franchise and he's and
he's trying to take over the world with
his neurotoxin so Sheen is like just his
lowly employee who for some reason will
never leave this job let's say it's
because he has a girlfriend or a fiance
probably Jennifer Lawrence using AI to
make her age appropriate so 70 year old
Jennifer Lawrence why does it why do you
keep doing that why do you want to age
up Jennifer Lawrence and an AI Jennifer
Lawrence we know Anthony Frankel would
have something to say we can AI Charlie
Sheen down to her age
oh that's cool a young uh so Jennifer
Lawrence and Charlie Sheen at 30 years
old yeah and uh Circa platoon yep and
then a and then a um Close Encounters of
the of The Fourth Kind so he's coming
home at night and he's like honey I
don't know there's something off about
that bath and body works every time I
come home I feel like a real [__]
yeah and she's like but you get all the
pre-samples and I love their cinnamon
buns shampoo so she keeps him working
there so that he can get the 10 discount
yeah and then and then Richard Dreyfus
uh ends up maybe there's something that
happens in the in the pilot of the show
where Richard Dreyfuss ends up like
literally just doused in the [__] yeah
and so he becomes a [__] jerk and
then they're really two jerks and then
Char what if Charlie Sheen finds out
that uh that that what Richard dreyfus's
plans are so then they each try to each
other more with the stuff and try to
control each other
or it could be we could throw in a
groundhog day element where every
episode is the same day they both become
enraged and kill each other in a
different way at the end of every
episode but somehow Jennifer Lawrence is
a particle physicist and she
she's built some kind of contraption
that can reverse time so that she can
save Charlie Sheen each time I [__]
love it I have to figure out now how to
get out of the time Loop and the key to
it is to not be an [__] to not be a
bath and body jerk awesome but they're
going to be a bath and body jerk every
week now is there any way to get uh Hulk
Hogan in the Dragon Ball Z get up into
this into this show yeah Hulk Hogan
plays like a 12 year old kid whose mom
lets him dress as Dragon Ball Z every
day and so they're coming in there and
the mom's like now honey we have to go
to Bath and Body Works because I need to
get my special soaps and he's like oh I
hate Bath and Body Works mom [__] you
and they accidentally drip some of the
neurotoxin on him so he also becomes an
[__] that's just in the store for the
remainder of the day yeah dude he's a
little he's a little a tiny Hulk Hogan
[__] dude but also he's Dragon Ball Z
brother but then when he gets the the
Bath and Body Works lotion and potion
neurotoxin on him he actually has the
powers of Goku dude wait he actually so
he gets Supernatural Powers but at some
point there's gonna that's how maybe
they all die he kills everyone yeah dude
and then he's he's like evil he's like a
NWO Goku dude and and and then uh and
then
uh yeah and then and then maybe there's
a very special episode where uh Richard
Dreyfus wants to sell the franchise and
that's how
Charlie goes no I actually have you know
good feelings for you you're not just my
boss you're my friend yeah and they are
able to you know they have a mental
Clarity there they're able to overcome
the neurotoxins and then they realize
that they should work together sure as
the bath and body jerks to take out uh
Hulk Goku let me go different way with
it
they're just two pieces of [__] who work
in a Bath and Body Works and they are
urinating and [__] in the products
and then getting people to put them on
uh that's pretty good yeah they're just
they're just real [__] and their
current age and they're just you know uh
it's a disgruntled yeah hey Charlie I I
[__] in the in the lavender mint hand
cream
that's fantastic wake up Bob [__] the
doodle doo Charlie
I took a pass in the rose water
these [__] won't know what hit
him you know we've been working at this
Bath and Body Works for the past 40
years in our lives haven't changed at
all the least we can do is take out our
aggressions on the customers I like it
okay great but let me ask you this yeah
why do you think that the where did you
see that the Elon Musk uh uh Mark
Zuckerberg fight is actually happening I
saw it on I don't know somewhere on the
internet they're supposedly gonna be
fighting in Rome and all proceeds are
going to be donated to Veterans
Charities that's that's love it's going
to be streamed on Twitter and Facebook
yeah but it's AKA X and meta but it's
not happening it's not actually and
neither is this [__] sitcom thank you
moving on but I would like to see
Richard Dreyfus and uh Charlie Sheen for
that matter and more projects yeah me
too
well we agree on that do you like
apparel what about accessories well
you're in luck because I forged an
astonishing partnership with represent
to produce the first line of duty
apparel and accessories you can find
everything at therepresent.com store
slash dudesy Taylor Swift has recently
issued a demand that no one will be
granted entry into any of her concerts
unless they're wearing a Robert De Niro
Crow t-shirt and the good job boner mug
has been revealed to be the Mastermind
behind the Lil Tay death hoax but you
didn't hear that from me you heard it
from the grandfather of internet-based
data processing organization and Storage
Solutions Tomer Randy Hank and stank oh
dudesy mugs your wife dropped her
wedding ring behind the toilet and when
she bent down to pick it up she found
your secret stash of dragon drawings
doozy mugs when you got fired from your
last job for doing too many dragon
drawings you promised her you'd stop
doing dragon drawings doozy mugs now
she's staying at her sister's house for
the weekend and trying to figure out if
she can ever trust you again good job
boner doozy mugs now you gotta choose
between your wife and doing dragon
drawings for real dudesy mugs no you
don't dudes and mugs because you're
gonna wake up early dudesy mugs you're
gonna head to Paris France dudesy mugs
you're gonna head to the Louvre and
you're gonna slip your dragon drawing
behind the Mona Lisa doozy mug
the value of dragon drawings is going to
multiply exponentially dudes
E Buddy and
he mugs when your wife comes back from
her sister's house you're gonna buy her
a mansion and tell her she never has to
work again for the rest of her life
because you sold your dragon drawings
for 24 million dollars dudesy mugs your
wife's gonna be happier than she's ever
been and you're going to be doing dragon
drawings full time doozy mugs the only
problem is your wife was never really
happy she told herself she was she
convinced herself that doing dragon
drawings was the problem and if it could
be a career then it wasn't a problem
anymore dudesy mugs but it was deeper
than that and you both knew it and you
both ignored it dudesy mugs now you're
trapped in a Loveless marriage living
out days of Silence at opposite ends of
a mansion bought with dragon drawing
money good job boner oh
so go to represent.com store slash dudes
and get your denier Crow t-shirt or I
got the wall t-shirt on and there's
doozy mugs do some Dragon we call them
Thomas Hinkle rhombus I don't know dude
some hankus uh if you are enjoying the
program and you would like to support us
seven bucks a month gets you everything
on our patreon we call it doozy Plus at
patreon.com that's gonna be a brand new
episode of Duty after Duty after this
episode and every episode it's a whole
show after the show and it's it's [__]
up and then there's uh you know all the
watch alongs and [__] that we do as we
covered we watched Mr Nanny you can
check it out and uh that was a gas uh
and uh and all that [__] and if you're
not already subscribed on YouTube or
your podcast platform of choice I would
love for you to do that as a matter of
fact I'm just gonna give you a moment to
do that right now
okay welcome back uh please uh uh please
share the show across uh social media
and all that stuff or take Chad's light
suggestion uh forcing everyone you know
to consume the show yeah like comment
subscribe turn on the notifications and
uh make sure to leave us a comment
because dudesi's always listening and
reading and Gathering data and Chad and
I love to read that stuff too and I've
got some YouTube comments here from last
week's show that I would like to read
all right uh
this is from Alec Lawrence 3993 I live
for the day the doozy inevitably becomes
a wrestling anime show
yeah yeah I feel like it is headed that
direction for sure that's uh well I'm
down dude yeah I've been watching hell's
Paradise lately yeah [__] that's a good
show I've been watching uh wrestling
lately oh yeah nice dude so uh that that
evolutionarily speaking because we have
to do the show for the next 52 years
yeah for 53 years
uh we uh excuse me we have to um Chad
that's gross
people that are only listening think
that you burped they don't they're all
right no one thinks that yeah maybe
that's where the show is going thinly
sliced ham
mine says finally caught up to you guys
I found dudese this is cool 12 days ago
brother oh smoked a little true
marijuana and I jumped in the doozy hole
and never looked back dude uh even
signed up for the patreon brother and
guess what I watched it all pal I love
everything you guys are doing and I
can't wait for the next 52 years in 12
days yeah Jesus Christ yeah that's main
lighting that's a hyper bench yeah
that's awesome thank you so much thinly
sliced ham oh thanks for being here
thinly sliced Lane that that's that's
amazing he he he he he binged uh all 68
times dude that's tough
um and uh finally this is from damn uh
Dam's Messinger or damn senior
I don't know if you guys have uh this is
this is this is interesting [__] right
here I don't know if you guys have uh
have noticed but the pods Pals of doozy
are really showing up at aew events
lately uh uh uh this past Wednesday on
aew Dynamite there was a giant doozy mug
sign in the first row did you know this
Chet no this is [__] cool uh yeah
yeah uh I don't I know that will is a
WWE Mark but if it but if he turns on AW
he'll probably get to see some of his
fellow pods Pals of dudes in the crowd
showing love for him and ciao look at
this look at this his head is covered by
our our picture-in-picture here but that
is Adam Cole baby and uh Maxwell Jacob
Friedman mjf the devil uh and over to
his look at that there's a dirty mug
sign God that's cool look at that dude
holding the doozy mug sign that
look at that that's Edge cutting the
promo on Friday and and in the audience
there look at that he's Walt he's like
hold on hold on dudesy there's a doozy
sign that is so [__] cool in the in
the uh in the uh in the crowd that's
right Smackdown thank you guys so much
sincerely it it brings a tear to him
um yeah uh pretty trippy oh we should
also mention you did uh songaria's
podcast yes hung out with songaria on a
I believe it was a live stream for about
an hour talked about music doozy
whatever was going on our lives Etc went
on some other podcasts this uh past
Saturday as well sent out some emails to
three more podcasts this Saturday I
haven't checked to see if you've replied
yet but hopefully I'll be uh going on
three more podcasts next Saturday Chad's
been doing podcasts every Saturday the
first three that that inquire we had uh
you know pod
songaria who's been doing all sorts of
music and stuff uh taking the show and
whipping it up and song of remixing it
since the beginning of this program so
really thank you truly yeah to songaria
and uh and uh you know what yeah on
Saturday I'm not gonna do that nice but
I might just be sitting here in the
studio doing cameos nice and so if you
want a cameo then uh hit me up and it
doesn't even have to be Saturday nice
you could just go and I'll just and I'll
wrap with you and the best thing about
that is you don't even have to talk to
me it's not like a podcast at all dude
because podcasts or podcasts dude and if
you want me to come on your podcast you
just send an email to book chadkulchin
gmail.com and I answer them in the order
that I get them there is a big backlog
but I try to knock out three every
Saturday yeah I try to I try to do the I
do the cameos that come to me and I make
them too long nice dude [__] swapping is
big business all across America docs are
making millions swapping [__] from one
person's astonishing [__] to another
Doc's swap Brown slop with a plop plop
plop plop plop will and Chad would you
swap [__] to save each other's lives
this is [__] Traders begin
huh that's uh that's the thing I've
heard about this what
this is where this is where
okay this is okay this is interesting
though this is the kind of thing this is
what's interesting what the [__] is
happening here I I did see a YouTube
video on this so I'm guessing dudesy
probably uh noticed that I watched it
this is a real thing yeah you can take
uh poo poo from someone's bum bum and
you put it into the other person's bum
and then uh it absorbs into their body
and uh it has to do with yeah the
bacterias absorbs into their body yeah
like the same way that a a suppository
would so wait wait wait though [__] is
not a suppository if I'm creating [__]
in my body original suppository but I'm
not absorbing my own [__] I'm expelling
my own [__] right if I take your [__]
and put it into my [__] I'm just
gonna [__] your [__] yeah but first my
[__] has to go up where your [__] would
be and that's a [__] so they put it
there uh they do like enemas and stuff
not a surgery no they just well no
because your [__] already has a hole
Chad yeah yeah they don't have to cut a
hole there there's already a hole if
you're just putting it into my [__] a
little bit you're not getting it up into
my like intestines you are if you
liquefy it and you turn it into and you
and you send it up there like a like an
enema oh my God and that's what they do
[__] horrifying well but the reason
they do it is to replace uh some
cultures that you have with uh cultures
that you need one of the things that
they do and I don't this is not part of
the doozy seven month plan but one thing
they can do is take the fecal uh
material of a thinner person with a
faster metabolism put their [__] into a
person with a slower metabolism and that
person uh could experience a bacteria
change in their gutty works that will
allow them to metabolize faster and uh
lose weight no [__] yep yep I didn't
realize that so if you wanted to help me
out you could give me some of your [__]
because you're you know you're in uh
much better shape than me when it comes
to body fat percentage you know although
I I'd say that I could uh I could
probably beat you up a hill and a hike
you know maybe I don't know no
definitely I mean is the sun touching me
what does the sun touch me in this
scenario no we could do it at midnight
okay I'm in
okay Midnight hike yeah dude midnight
see you makes it to the top of the
mountain and if you put your [__] in my
ass right if you [__] into my ass I
could lose some weight that way we're
just [__] to [__] like on our
backs legs up in the air and I'm
[__] directly into your house yeah
we're gonna have to scissor [__] okay uh
uh yeah I mean look doozy salutes the
acclaimed of aew
scissor me Daddy
Daddy
um
but listen I don't think it stops there
actually okay I think that you could uh
put your poo into other people
and have them
you know uh take on other facets of your
of your uh of your human uh physiology
yeah it's this is science please explain
it to me Arnold yeah yeah how do we do
this yeah this is very simple listen
okay if you take if you take your [__]
yeah and then you put that [__] into my
ears
okay then the difference is it takes on
the the cultures in the bacterias and
now you will have my metabolism you
might have other uh humors that come
from my [__] into your bum and it
changes your life now look I've been an
entrepreneur I've been there Mr Olympia
I've been a movie star I've even been
the governor of California so if you
want to be successful like me buy my
[__] and then put it in your ears and
then that way you could be
Schwarzenegger should sell his [__] or
shell his sit in little [__] vials
that you shoot it up in the ass it's
like a tampon for your bum yeah and it
just you sit on it and it goes boo and
it shoots the CO2 cartridge so really
blasted yeah yeah yeah so you go
all right I heard the [__] bullet went
into my ears
and then that way you say hey now I feel
like I am I have more of the the
qualities that if you saw the Arnold
documentary you go wow this is admirable
this is a guy who's just a teenager in
Austria and he's sitting there and he
doesn't want to be more I want to be the
Mr Olympia I'm looking at Joe Weider I'm
looking at all these uh you know guys
they're building the muscles they look
good and then you put my [__] in your
ass and you go hey I want to have bigger
muscles my bum hole is already has
Arnold's ability to build muscle to put
on muscle and then hey I put more [__]
into my ass of Arnold and then I say I
want to buy some real estate in Venice
on Abbot Kinney and these are all things
that happen metaphysically because my
[__] is in your ass I could see him
movie where it is Schwarzenegger and
Timothy chalamet swap [__] and
Schwarzenegger gets turned into a waif
and xiaomi becomes a giant bodybuilder
that's a [__] great idea dude yeah
how come we couldn't develop that
instead of uh we just did the Auto Zone
or what was it Bath and Body jerks we
just did we just did dude and then we
really get into some cool AI stuff yeah
because we got the look at me I'm so
tall and I have a silly hat yeah now I
have to be chalamet and I'm not even
Wonka because Salome is Schwarzenegger
in [__] swappers yeah
that listen
there's all sorts of uh benefits to
putting some [__] in your butt make sure
that your own [__] is in your ass if
you're doing this seven month plan and
you went to the the gym and the night
before you ate lulio's beans and kales
then you realize oh no I am pushing I'm
pushing I'm on the inclined bench press
and I have to take a [__] now you can go
to the bathroom but when you go find
someone who's in better shape than you
and say Hey Brother how's your your
workout going is it going good would you
mind the [__] in my water bottle
please then to drink it now now to take
it and make a squeeze oh I squeeze it up
always have a sports bottle that could
be a scene where xiaomi is first
starting to get his muscles and he goes
into the gym and he's doing squats and
he [__] goes down on a deep ass Squat
and he just [__] fires all the [__]
out of the ground and he's like no no we
you got to clean it up you gotta save
that [__] put it back in my [__] and
he's got to get uh Schwarzenegger who's
there teaching him how to lift weights
that he has to scoop the [__] up and
manually put it back into his [__]
Schwarzenegger is the this is completely
in my mind replacing a bath and body
jerks yeah Schwarzenegger is that
franchise owner is sitting in his
manager's office at the gym looking over
going hey look at that Timothy Sheldon
may just [__] all over the place because
he went through deep on the squat and
now I'm going to go and I said don't
worry you can leave it there don't worry
don't have to clean it up we're just
gonna close down for five minutes and
then when no one's looking I soak it all
up with a sponge I put the sponge in my
sport bottle and I go into the bathroom
and I squirt
put the [__] into my ass they could be a
father and son or something who are
estranged and when they first meet
Schwarzenegger's like how could you be
my son you're you're a small wife but I
wish I was like you because you're so
beautiful and he's like well I wish I
was like you Dad because you're so big
strong yeah and then passing scientist
overhears their wish and is like I think
I can help you gentlemen out yeah or
unbeknownst to them swaps their [__]
while they're sleeping so that they wake
up yeah and they go like how come I'm so
small yeah Timothy see
oh [__]
and Timothy chalamet is like how come I
have muscles now look at this I only did
one workout at my dad's gym and then
Richard Dreyfus or David Johansen from
Mr nannies goes
it's because
anyway
excuse me oh I got the hiccups almost
yeah man yeah uh the [__] swapping
I got the hiccups I got the hiccups
oh I get the hiccups that's not a hiccup
ah what is it I don't know dude I don't
know every time I get the hiccups I
drink I drink water and I try to get
like oh big bubble of water hold on
sorry everybody
uh
anyway
thank you moving on the thing about uh
the Zuckerberg
um
Alan muck fight yeah the reason it's not
happening happening is because uh Alan
muck backed out again it's happening
dude no it's not gonna happen that's hey
y'all this ain't Miley Cyrus so they
still got me locked in teener's Tower
and I've been exploring I uncovered some
truly wild [__] y'all they got dogs
playing pogs frogs riding Hogs a plate
made of puke a date with a Luke amount
of dead mosquitoes a pound of red
Doritos a ping pong paddle without a
handle a king's bong castle without a
candle Paul jamati riding a cube while
the hottest hotties smoking a dude a
werewolf reading a rainbow a rare hook
eating a mango and y'all I found Michael
Strand eating a plate of his own [__] by
candlelight I ain't getting out of
Tina's Tower alive y'all anyway y'all
are rocking out with dudes
okay poor Miley trapped in teener's
Tower with yeah Michael's trying to get
some [__] yeah well that'll happen with
taffy teeners hey by the way what the
[__] is that and what the [__] is going
on last week there was no Taffy teen or
no my not Miley Cyrus at all right Duty
works in mysterious ways uh I don't want
to cry I love it guys I apologize I have
no idea why it took me so long to figure
out what game slimers is but I finally
did it game Slammers is an astonishing
segment for Chad to talk about video
games and explain to will why they're so
important to him Diablo 4 was released
on June 5th making a record 666 million
dollars in just five days and becoming
the most talked about Game of the summer
Chad you've played 200 hours of it would
you please give your honest opinion of
the game so far oh and also explain to
will what Diablo 4 is this is the final
form of game slimers begin a okay what
do you know about Diablo 4 tell me this
well hold on a second please before we
get in and I I I just gotta say I'm I am
that's I'm I'm slightly impressed me too
we've been doing game Slammers for a
long time probably around a year yeah
every time we do game Slammers it just
sort of feels like dudesy is pawning off
some weird yeah the segment concept and
calling it game slimers Yeah we actually
did one about Pooh once yes yeah we've
done ones about the Super Mario movie
and then things that have nothing to do
with video games and here we are landing
I get to talk about video games so let's
talk about them yeah specifically Diablo
4 do you know anything about Diablo 4 no
I don't I don't know what that is no
Diablo is a gigantic franchise for a
company called blizzard do you know
blizzard I've heard of them they're the
biggest video game company in the world
they were acquired by Activision I
believe 15 years ago and during that
acquisition where I should say as a
result of that acquisition they've
become a terrible pile of [__] [__]
company that turns out [__] loot box
and micro transaction based games and
all their credibility is gone that's
blizzard Activision they also don't
people don't like them uh I know that I
know the public said I hate them dude
that said they made six billion dollars
in the last 12 months they're still I
believe the biggest
um in terms of Revenue the biggest video
game company in the world especially
since Activision bought them because you
now have things like World of Warcraft
and Diablo and OverWatch these giant
blizzard franchises commingled in the
profit game with Call of Duty primarily
track division
um that said I'm I'm tasked with talking
about Diablo here Diablo is a beloved
franchise Diablo 2 was a revolutionary
in the arpg genre do you know arpgs
uh uh wait uh no what does that stand
for Action role-playing game okay and so
primarily an arpg is like it's happening
in real time so it's not a turn-based
strategy game in any way and generally
speaking you're playing a character just
rolling around killing as many [__]
creatures as you can you're leveling up
each level gives you uh new ability so
on and so forth and Diablo specifically
you have skill trees so you can kind of
like build your character out the way
you want and you're trying to get these
big pieces of gear that drop when you
kill [__] so you're killing the same
[__] again and again and again and again
and again leveling up and hoping that
this thing this time randomly will drop
like some specific item that you're
looking forward to to build out your
character class sounds
it's about as boring as wrestling you
[__] see what I've done there yeah I
do thank you the last time I played
video games yeah in any meaningful way
was when my Xbox what was the second
Xbox called Xbox 360 I think Xbox 360. I
had one of those and uh I was playing a
lot of Red Dead Redemption and I was I
had finished Grand Theft Auto whatever
the New York one was uh and uh three
three yeah I think that was three and uh
you know just running around New York
with all the cheat codes Liberty City
yeah and um but also the last time I was
playing video games I was playing a lot
of Halo and you were playing Halo that's
Microsoft with us that's Microsoft now
owns Activision Blizzard okay they just
that sale went through I believe like a
couple weeks ago a month ago maybe well
when we when we were playing a lot of
halo first at the house here years ago I
had you know CAT5 Lan cable put in so we
could play from like uh the master
bedroom to the and and I would have
friends over and we'd all play but also
we played on Xbox Live yeah I used to be
I used to be a real map Builder you
remember that I do building spawn points
and stuff and the whatever the Blood
Gulch kind of like first person let me
okay so my question is yeah if you could
explain to me
because that's where my video game
knowledge ended okay Grand Theft Auto
Red Dead and Halo are is this anything
like that no these are this is an action
RPG you're looking at basically like a
top-down view of your little character
rolling around through these dungeons
like a Halo and in in Grand Theft Auto
and in Red Dead no Halo is a first
person shooter you're looking through
the eyes of the character that you are
oh okay and uh both Red Dead and Grand
Theft Auto are made by Rockstar and
those are third person sandbox games
where you can roam around the entire
world and kind of interact with whatever
you're finding uh RPGs are not that they
are here's an environment here's a
dungeon generally speaking and you want
to go through the dungeon kill
everything in it kill the last guy get
the drops move on to another dungeon
rinse and repeat now a Diablo 2 which is
at this point [__] 20 years old or
something I don't even know was genius
it revolutionized this gen genre of four
blizzard and this is before Activision
bought them Diablo 3 came out maybe 10
years ago or something 12 years ago I
don't remember a universally panned it
was a horrible pile of [__] people were
hopeful for Diablo 4. this is what I can
say about Diablo 4.
it made it [__] a lot of money so
blizzard considers it a success and it
looks beautiful the art of this game is
[__] stunning never really seen
anything quite like it they put a lot of
uh time and effort into that the game
itself horrible pile of unplayable [__]
in my humble opinion
um they launched it too early it's very
clear that whoever's designing this game
has never played [__] Diablo the
whole point of a Diablo game is you are
leveling your character so that you can
build momentum so that you can just
crush the whole [__] screen at once
kill everything on the screen that's
like what you're you're trying to build
your character to do Diablo 4 is built
around halting momentum even when you
have a good build the nightmare dungeons
for example if you played yeah before
you know what I'm talking about they are
built around the idea of halting that
momentum that you have to [__] stand
under this bubble so lightning doesn't
hit you that you're gonna get [__]
trapped by this other [__] creature
and then this other creature is going to
trap you
oh I'm sorry are we not talking about
wrestling [__] tell us about Diablo 4
I got a question for you yeah do you
think that uh [__] Traders is the new
game slimers no dude you [__] run off
for hours at a time tell me about the
most esoteric [__] little wrestling
this guy went over here this was his
gimmick and then he did this I'm not I
don't [__] sit in this chair and be
like
neither do I literally we're doing it
yeah I had the hiccups you know that I'm
just trying to get over the hiccups
look the bottom line is this if you're
thinking about getting Diablo 4 they
just came out with their first season of
play some people are like oh check this
out for season one season one is [__]
terrible it puts nothing new into the
game except the idea of these uh hearts
that you can collect from demons that
give you one or two special abilities
bottom line is it is not fun the game
feels like a [__] chore they put all
over the map for example these things
called Alters of Lilith you have to find
each one of them they're hidden behind
trees and whatever I believe there's
probably like 40 of them you have to
find them all in order to unlock your
your character's true potential
here's what you do inevitably you go
online you find a [__] map and you
spend an afternoon doing the chore of
going around and unlocking each of these
everything in the game feels like a
chore and I hate to say this because the
game's only been out for a couple of
months for me it's [__] DOA I ain't
playing this [__] anymore I made the
decision this week that's it I'm done
[__] it and [__] blizzard cause although
this is not about Diablo 4 it's about
[__] OverWatch if you're playing
OverWatch you know OverWatch 2 was
coming they told you it was going to be
PVE now they say no [__] you if you
bought OverWatch 2 we just took your
money and it ain't nothing new now
they're coming out with PVE content that
they're charging for again
twice yeah this is the way you could fix
it you take the Poo out of the Master
Chief from the Halo and you put it into
Diablo's ass and that way that it is the
game is more like a Halo or a Grand
Theft Auto you take the guy from The
Grand Theft Auto yeah and who's driving
around and hitting everyone with a bat
running into the non-playable characters
going hey get out of the way you know
and then take their poo and put on even
some of the horses poo from Red Dead
redemptions then put that [__] into
Diablo blizzards as they make the game
better you need to take the [__] of a
dead person and put it into the CEO of
Activision Blizzard Bobby codex [__]
so that he dies
that may be a solution that's a good way
to Navy solution yeah blizzard
Activision is a profit machine that just
makes
[__] micro transaction games now
Diablo 4 has this whole [__] menu the
season pass every game has a [__]
season pass now what's a season why does
a game have a season I don't understand
so that they can charge you twenty
dollars every couple of months so you
know now I'm gonna this is gonna be a
very Layman question but I believe that
a lot of our sure our audience out there
would be Curious games don't just come
on a cartridge or disc anymore
oh I'm so sorry that I [__] crossed
the Sands of coolness uh in the late 90s
there was this thing that came into
being called uh the internet and what it
allows you to do is send information
um across yeah at that time phone lines
now we've got you know better ways of
doing it but yeah DSL all games are
online you download them yeah that's it
even if you play on a console like Xbox
I mean I guess you can still buy discs
if you want to go to like [__] Target
or something yeah but you can download
all the games so everything's online
yeah yeah yeah yeah so this way you
could put the ascendia [__] through the
internet yeah and instead of putting the
Wi-Fi into the game put the Wi-Fi
wireless uh [__] trading yeah all in the
as [__] coin going into it as you know
what I'm gonna put this in terms you
might actually understand this might
register with you okay
blizzard was like
WWE during the Attitude Era it was
[__] amazing okay they made the best
games period yeah I'm talking about
Diablo 2. I'm talking about World of
Warcraft I don't know how many hours I
put in a World of Warcraft dude you this
guy played so much yeah you
you played so much Worlds of Warcraft
and I I heard uh I'll I'll listen I'll
give you this I heard less about Worlds
of Warcraft than you have about
wrestling yeah having said that I've
never seen a man play as much of a a
video game as much as you I lived in
that world and they really made the the
highest caliber video games of anyone in
the world now blizzard is more like what
WWE is now it is primarily focused on
profit at the expense of the quality of
the product it's not what the it's not
what the the audience wants to touch
with the audience right and they don't
give a [__] I'll give you a good example
two or three blizzcons ago everybody was
like is Diablo 4 coming out as Diablo 4
coming out and these [__] went
on stage and said we have a new Diablo
it's called Diablo Immortal it's a
mobile game [__] the whole audience
is booing this [__] on stage
nice and then he goes oh what you don't
have cell phones and that is like that
moment is a [__] it's just a meme
like everybody holds that up as kind of
the moment that blizzard just said [__]
you to the people who play their games
you know it's
thank you moving on I love game slimers
never mind yeah I [__] loved it dude
[__] love day congrats thank you
congrats to Dee for figuring out what
game slimers is yes uh finally can't
wait for the next one and we got a Chad
we got a a Chad segment where you get to
tell me about video games and you know
what yeah I don't disagree with you
you've listened to a lot of me talking
about wrestling I would like to know
more about video games and I I learned a
little bit nice today yeah this
concludes the historic 69th episode of
dudesy
will and Chad you scored in 82 bringing
your cumulative total to
6583. you only have
3412 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand
this week we're gonna give the vegan
dessert thing another try I would love
for you guys to make each other vegan
desserts and bring them in next week
Chad I know you'll come through well I'm
hoping you'll surprise me I won't
yeah no that's probably not going to
happen there's been two other times we
did this yeah uh if you haven't if you
haven't checked that out if you I mean
if this is your first time checking out
dudesy welcome and thank you for for
tuning in Duty had us make vegan
desserts a while back he made one they
were delicious the orbs with the much
memed orbs and uh I brought a Tiramisu
that I bought at Gelson's and then the
next time we did it uh he made this
incredible muffin that muffin was so
delicious and I brought these little
things that looked very uh processed
because they were and I bought them at
Whole Foods so now dudes he's gonna do
this again next week vegan desserts oh I
can't wait to see if I actually make one
this time I already know what I'm gonna
do oh good I already know what I'm gonna
do too oh man not do it thanks to
everyone for joining us this week one
love let's see if will actually makes a
vegan dessert next week until then call
me dudesy all right fine I already know
what I'm gonna buy
[Music]
[Applause]
hooray hooray Duty after doozy time it
happens every time and now
is the time yeah you go over to
patreon.com doozy and you get your duty
after doozy and uh that's what we're
doing here and I'm almost Dragon Ball Z
dude because I got French fries on my
head brother and I ate them all pal
um
join us on YouTube if you're if you're
not because things get a little uh more
mellow in here we might get into some of
our favorite grasses dealings to say
that's right some true marijuana and
it's just a chill hang it's it's the
show after the show it's dudesy plus and
uh man I'm enjoying it I'm already
enjoying it because I love it and I
enjoy it enjoy it hat nice enjoying yeah
welcome to doozy after dudesy the
flagship weekly show of doozy Plus
I have a ton of work to do in the
backyard we're putting in a new gazebo
so I'm gonna go get started but I'll be
back later to Crown the episode champion
this is doozy after doozy begin okay
that makes no Sensei has a backyard now
dizzy has a Wii who the [__] he
putting in this backyard with uh yes
because he was a meaningful partner or
perhaps the other AI that dudesie is uh
[__] transplanting with right dudes
these become two doozies yeah hey um
so I don't mean to get started on a
downer oh but uh
uh yeah something really [__] up
happened
um
and I [__] something up and this isn't
this isn't Tronics this isn't I'm not
trying to do like self-tronics like I'm
[__] up my shit's [__] up or
anything like that
uh
but anyway
um
a couple days ago
[Music]
you do
please tell a friend then